-Our first guest tonight is
an Emmy and Tony Award-winning
actress
you know from her work
on "The Good Wife,"
"The Gilded Age,"
and the "Mamma Mia" movies.
She stars in the sixth,
and final, season
of "The Good Fight"
which premiers this Thursday
on Paramount+.
Let's take a look.
-I really don't know
why I'm here. [ Chuckle ]
Well, I think my world feels
a little --
a little bit out of control.
I feel like we're
on this hamster wheel.
No matter what we do, we just
end up back at the start,
you know?
I used to believe in progress,
that --
that...people learn
from their mistakes,
that things got better, and --
and here we are.
-Please welcome back to the show
one of our favorites --
Christine Baranski, everybody!
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Funk plays ]
♪♪
-How are you?!
-I know.
Back from summer vacation.
-Back from summer vacation.
You're a working actress.
I feel like you don't really
have your summers off.
-I didn't, not this summer.
I worked "Good Fight"
through July
and then I had a day off
and then I went right
into "Gilded Age,"
but I've had a little bit
of time.
-Well, I was very lucky in the
early parts of the summer.
We've talked in the past
about that fact that our --
my children, and your
grandchildren are very close.
-I know, the last time
I saw you, really,
you were mounting an inflatable
water trampoline.
[ Laughter ]
-I was.
-I wish I had a video of it.
-I'm glad you don't have
a video of me,
[ Laughter ]
but you brought one
of your grandson.
-I did.
-Do you want
to set up the video?
And let me just say,
I really appreciate,
as a grandmother, that you're
going to share it with us.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, here's the thing.
We have a long dock
and then we have
a water trampoline
and the water trampoline
kind of floats away.
Well, Christopher,
my son-in-law,
jumped from the dock
onto the water trampoline
and then Max, my oldest one,
my eight-year-old,
went from the dock
onto the water trampoline.
But Auggie --
-Yeah.
-Yeah, here's Auggie.
[ Laughter ]
-I think you've set it up
very well.
Let's take a look at Auggie
trying to do the same.
-Ah!
-Oh!
[ Laughter and applause ]
-He's okay.
-He's fine.
-I mean, he's not going to be
fine when he finds out
that his grandmother showed that
on national television.
-No, actually, I asked him.
-Did you really?
-He's very excited.
He's very excited.
-That's great.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, I will say,
my experience with Auggie is
he's very robust.
I am not surprised that he was
uninjured by that.
-No. But can you imagine needing
rhinoplasty in first grade?
[ Laughter ]
I was delighted.
It's a very funny memory.
-So, my kids know you as Minnie,
which is what your grandchildren
call you.
-Everybody, everybody at the
beach, I'm just Minnie.
-You're just Minnie.
It's great.
-I love and then they hug me,
"Bye, Minnie,"
and "When are we going
to Minnie's house?"
It's something
that I'm very proud of,
that kids like to come
to Minnie's house.
And you like it there, too,
don't you?
-I do like it there
a great deal.
I mean, now I'm a little worried
about my privacy
because you share videos.
[ Laughter ]
-My favorite was watching adults
try and mount the trampoline
and then drag their kids out.
-Yes, I actually
don't blame Auggie
for trying to jump on,
because it's not as easy
crawling up the side ladder
as you look.
I want to ask you --
So, we had a moment.
We were listening
to the "Mamma Mia!" soundtrack,
as we do,
and we realized
we could tell the boys,
"Oh, that's Minnie's voice."
And it did not register
with them at all.
It was too big a leap
for their logic to make.
-Do you want me to
make a house call
and sing all the song.
-We would love you to come over.
[ Laughter ]
-♪ You can dance ♪
♪ You can dance ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Do your...
I mean, you know,
most of your work
is obviously, I would imagine,
fairly adult.
Do your grandkids --
have they made the connection
that you are on-screen?
-They're curiously
so uninterested.
They don't get all excited.
They watch "The Grinch,"
and it's like,
"Oh, yeah, that's Minnie."
But other kids come up,
"Oh! Oh, you're in 'Mamma Mia!'"
"Oh, you're Martha May
in "The Grinch."
And my own grand--
which is fine.
-Yeah.
-I actually don't want to be
a famous person to them.
-You want to be Minnie.
And you're an excellent Minnie.
You can do both.
Speaking of doing both,
you are playing two characters
about 100 years apart
in American history.
-Both of them in despair
about the state of the world.
-Exactly.
-I just transfer one --
-It's helpful to remember
that Diane obviously
is very in despair
about the present.
But then Agnes thought
we were in, you know,
we were going to [Bleep]
100 years ago.
-Yeah, she actually...
Agnes -- I do empathize
with Agnes.
She's having the equivalent
of a Trump hotel
built across from her brownstone
on East 61st Street.
And they're just hauling in
all these artifacts,
and it's all this, you know,
display of wealth,
which Agnes finds
just appalling.
These people think
they can buy their way
into society with money.
And she thinks that money's
going to just wreck the world.
And hello.
-She didn't do a terrible job
of calling it.
Is it tricky?
I mean, you know, obviously,
you're a seasoned pro
at this sort of thing,
but when you're basically
going back and forth
between seasons
of these two characters,
do you ever find one
bleeding into the other?
Is it very easy for you
to keep them separate?
-I think it's important the way
you speak, above all,
because once
you're in that corset,
you ain't going anywhere.
It's just like,
"Oh, yeah, I'm Agnes."
[ Laughter ]
But you know, Diane --
although Diana is well-spoken,
it's definitely a contemporary,
like, kind of like
I'm talking now.
But Agnes, definitely,
we have a speech coach,
and it has to be
much more precise.
And the attitude
and the whole manner
is so much more restrictive.
But, you know, it's a champagne
problem for an actor.
"Oh, my gosh,
I've got two shows.
I've got all these lines.
I have to switch over."
I mean, I'm
not going to complain.
-Yeah, you should do
a master class of, like,
"How do you handle two leads?"
[ Laughter ]
-So, somebody's got to do it.
-I have a lot more to ask you,
especially
about the final season
of "The Good Fight."
We'll be right back with
more from Christine Baranski.